[Music]
one of the first times i ever smoked
marijuana i was a teenager i was driving
um down the street of my hometown and i
had just smoked pot for the first time
and so i must have been driving very
slowly but i was feeling really good
so slowly that uh when i got up to a red
light
a cop to my right
uh put his one of those really bright
lights on a cop car directly onto my
face
and and said uh over the his loudspeaker
is everything okay i get very nervous
around authority and uh i rolled down
the window
and the thing i thought to tell him was
um
was this i said i'm so sorry officer i'm
just really nervous right now i am and
i'm excited i i i just lost my virginity
and
he smiled and said ah well
congratulations or something like that
rolled up his window turned off his
light and just kept driving
and it worked um
and uh and then 17 years later you
actually lost your virginity
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
from wondering this is life is short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Applause]
[Music]
and as always i'm here with my brother
christian hi my oh oh yeah yeah feeling
good today playful feeling plucky
um
yeah so that story about the uh of
course i hadn't yet lost my virginity
not of course i didn't mention that you
joked about it but of course
people have seen my high school yearbook
photo they know i was still a virgin it
was like a little larva i also have a
problem with
not a problem with authority but a
slight fear
yeah i'm like yeah you're like marlon
brando yeah i don't i don't take any
[ __ ] from cops what are you rebelling
against what do you got i'm
i'm the opposite of that guy the first
time i ever got pulled over by a cop i
was unprepared
i was driving home from i was in college
in upstate new york and i was driving
home to my girlfriend at the time's
senior prom in high school that's right
guys
still dating a high school senior um
great great move by the way i highly
recommend that to uh college students to
maintain romantic relationship a long
distance
it's a really smart move
um idiot i was driving home from upstate
new york back to connecticut to attend
this prom and i had just uh
days earlier had gotten into
this band in college well christian
calls it a band and if that's uh the
joke that we were he was always like
yeah i was in a band sounds so much
cooler than that okay it's it was an
all-male acapella group but i consider
the human voice in instruments so yeah
there were instruments in my band
so i was in an all-male acapella group
called the cool game
i i did base i did basically i did but
you played i played bass
so i was driving home
and
learning i was trying to learn my parts
because there were like a hundred
different songs in the repertoire so i
was listening uh on your set on my on my
uh
on the cd of of the songs i was trying
to pick out the bass parts and i was
driving and those upstate new york roads
are so
desolate and you can just you can just
go fast and shout out to route two yeah
route 17 in this case so i was going um
too fast
listening to these songs and i saw cop
lights behind me and i
remember just
freezing just freaking out and getting
so nervous and i especially that age oh
my god i pulled over
and i still remember the lights and and
all i remember from then on where i my
heart was beating so
intensely and that's all i could hear i
was like dun dun dun dun dun you know
what you think like well that's it
that's my luck yeah
it's like i had murdered 100 people and
i was and i was you know about to pay
for it it's like christopher lloyd and
back to the future oh my god they found
me i don't know how but they found me
yeah they're living
so he got out of his car and i remember
seeing him approach the state trooper
it's so scary with a big
wide-brimmed hat and he approached and
he looked like square you know just the
stereotype of the state trooper and do
you know that you were going 82 and a 55
and he was he really laying into me and
i
again
and at one point in the middle of his
rant
he stopped and poked his head farther
into the car
and said sorry is that peter gabriel
and as he said that the sound in my car
came back to me it was an acapella
version of in your eyes
and i said
yeah yeah officer
what it is it's a delight
it is i i just got at this acapella
group and i'm so excited about it i you
know i did something similar to the yeah
you did probably and he said
oh i love that so he's like i i was in
my college a cappella group
and
and he said what part what part do you
say what they said oh i sing bass he
said i sing bass that's crazy and he he
lit up and he was so excited about it
and we we connected over it and he said
take it easy on the gas pedal or
something and and he kind of gave me a
knowing smile and he said enjoy that
group and he walked away let me offer
the warning didn't have to pay for it
and uh crazy so the lesson is obviously
join that
learn how to harmonize yeah and you'll
be yeah you'll be safe the only way that
story would have been better is if you
had it ended with you guys singing the
rest of the song together and he took
the part he played and you were like
in your eyes heat the light the light
the heat
pump
every time you sing an acapella song
yeah i go to sandman it's mr sandman
yeah
um
i mentioned that story because uh our
guest today is the very funny
uh neil brennan he's a comedian who
we're gonna talk about it a lot he's got
a special on netflix called three mics
and he
draws the analogy of when you're
driving
next to a cop instinctively i think we
all do this you you try to play it cool
yeah and you try to kind of be normal
and he says when you're around a
celebrity
everyone sort of instinctively feels
that way yeah so that analogy is
in terms of like being around a
celebrity and neil calling himself a
starfighter it's such a
an ugly thing it's such a but everyone
can relate to that and that's what's
great about neil's comedy um
it's so honest it's so revealing
revealing like difficult things to talk
about things that are very difficult for
people to reveal and neil does it uh in
such an open honest way that um i really
admire in this special three mics that
you should all see on netflix if you
haven't already which we'll talk about
17 times yeah can we interview
the the
the setup is basically three different
microphones one microphone is for
one-liners one microphone is for sort of
more traditional stand-up longer longer
form jokes and the third microphone is
just for
sort of honest private admissions about
his family and things almost like
therapy
and he keeps bouncing from a microphone
to microphone and it's so good and
uh it's so compelling and it's so funny
and uh just good and interesting and
insightful and you should all watch yeah
and neil's like that and my favorite
comedians are like that i think um he's
great so for those who don't know him he
co-created chappelle's show dave
chappelle and
he wrote um
he wrote half-baked and this was our
first
live yeah recordings of uh podcasts and
right away it was
it was just such a different experience
having an audience there and for me
uh
i didn't know that i was gonna be part
of this interview and i you'll you'll
you'll hear it and i i kind of am not
part of it i say like three things so um
i hope you guys enjoy this this is uh
our first yeah first live podcast with
neil brennan right after this
thank you guys for being here uh
it's been so it's been so fun doing the
show because um
we were just talking about you don't
have to worry about what you look like
you don't have to worry about doing in
front of people normally yeah yeah um
a year ago i was doing i did a charity
event guys um that's the end of the
story thank you
thank you if you learned nothing from
tonight remember that justin did one
charity yeah and that's the end of the
story
um i and i you know i was trying to get
uh friends of mine to to participate and
um
i texted a a bunch of people and there
was you know maybe i could make it maybe
i can i texted neil and he just wrote
yes and um
when uh and that's that was it and i and
a similar thing happened with this where
i said hey you don't want and of course
i framed it like you probably don't want
to do this because it's available that's
what i'm getting from this
well what how i guess my question is
because i know what a pain in the ass it
is to book a podcast especially really
anything
i say it's like jury duty like you just
the joke is of course jury duty uh
doesn't ask you to tweet about it later
but um
where's podcasting they're like hey man
what traps would you mind trying to get
the word out yeah that'd be great uh so
that would make every all of you in a
court of law right now uh neil is um
a co-creator of the chappelle show and
he is a one of the best one of my
favorite stand-up comedians uh he has a
special called three mics on netflix if
you haven't seen it
you shouldn't be listening to this uh
you should be watching that um
you speak so eloquently
and about your family and that that i
don't really want to get
well eloquently it's a big word yeah go
ahead well you do it's uh and so i don't
i don't know how much of that to get
into but um whatever you want to talk
about you're the youngest of of ten
um yeah well ten kids is too many i
don't know if you know anything about
numbers or people or was that just
because they were catholic was that just
because they were and yeah and they were
very much in love
uh and my my dad love [ __ ] they
couldn't keep their hands off each other
yeah uh but were they at all
affectionate with each other because the
picture you paint of your photos
like
my mom is 85 now my dad is dead
so they don't have sex anymore they
don't i mean certainly not as much
um
soon sorry and
uh
so they're from the generation where
like they wouldn't they'd show affection
on like their anniversary you know what
i mean yeah we got like with a toast
yes like you know i love you that kind
of thing
[Laughter]
yeah there'd be some arm like shoulder
squeezing yeah sometimes yeah
yeah yeah and pecs like i'd see them but
never saw them i mean thankfully i guess
they're not carefully well they didn't
love [ __ ] like my parents
uh
jesus what that but it was was it so
that were they religious was it a
catholic yeah they were really
uh yeah i went to catholic school for 12
years all my brothers and sisters went
to catholic school
you say a great thing about in three
mics about
going to church um at a certain point
it's kind of like playing i mean you say
it better than i will but it's like
playing the trombone at a certain well
you just at a certain point after like
12th grade you're like [ __ ] that why am
i doing it um yeah like i don't have to
do that anymore so but did that affect
you at all i mean it gets a bigger laugh
on three months don't worry about it
guys oh no we're gonna turn all this up
oh sorry are you going to swing this
thing oh none of this is going to be
used it's sound man i'm going to get
into the sound it's all over yeah uh we
got a great laugh guy um
but but but
but did that affect you i mean how much
did that affect you because it did
catholicism yeah i think uh anyone who
grows up catholic
will tell you it is
like an almost impossible spell
to break i'm like now an atheist and i'm
still like
i might as well not be i might as well
go to i mean in terms of like mentality
and like
like everything somebody's difficult and
you're bad and just all this like it's
the guilt yeah is that the word all
right i think
i mean it informs yeah you're right it's
still you also said something on if you
should follow neil on instagram uh it's
it's funny and informative uh
you said something about how change can
occur unless you are unless you will not
people do not change unless they uh
go to 12-step meetings like every day
or almost die i can't stop thinking
about that it's kind of true like people
don't really i mean when people go like
i change we're like
there's a band-aid yeah like you gotta
no i'm doing it your hair's pink if
you're still talking exactly if you're
still talking if you haven't if you have
a bracelet about it it's probably not
gonna
probably i'm living differently see yeah
oh well then there it is
no further questions
that's the
but what what has forced you what are
some of the things that have forced you
to make real changes i mean in terms of
atheism like depths of misery i'd say or
or um
or
like
levels of misery
is a good one and then i would just go
to like
uh 12-step programs that i you don't
talk about but like gone to 12-step
programs uh for codependents and that
was probably my that's my because i
don't really drink or do drugs
significantly
never not that i don't
i've done cocaine once if you want the
stats do you want to try it again i
would i mean does anybody no one i never
i've only seen it maybe six times i
don't know what kind of vibe i'm giving
i thought it was a party vibe but i
guess not
and uh like so uh just getting in sort
of codependent relationships and then
finally just getting so miserable from
it that i had to start going to a daily
media yeah and that's kind of the thing
that like and then you know i mostly
have overcome it
are there in the relationships they're
so patterns the same patterns in these
relationships yeah that you have to know
like like charismatic people yeah and
then getting just swept up in it
yeah i i i don't have much experience
with that um
you you have uh oh yeah yeah
yeah um
you have one older brother who is uh who
was is he still a comedian yes is that
kind of what gave you
yeah that was i was in high school and
he was a comedian in new york so i just
go up from philly to like hang out at
comedy clubs and uh to see him yeah but
he would be working and i would see like
romano and john stewart and dave attel
and all these guys before they were
successful you were working the door
right i worked the door at a comedy club
when i went to nyu i would i went to nyu
for a year and worked the door of the
company and why did you leave nyu uh
because film students are loathsome
next question
[Laughter]
how lonesome are they
um uh no i just didn't i didn't i was
like it was like film students on the
one hand and then
like
comedians on the other hand and they
were the comedians that it was like
like i said romano john stewart david
tell louis
chappelle was the only one my age how
soon then after that meeting um or
getting to know him did you then start
writing uh it was one of these things
where i was secretly pining ah for it
huh um it really was like a [ __ ] like
a romantic comedy where i was like yeah
but what if we were well i don't know
it's just crazy
and i would give him a crazy thought i
would give him makeovers all the time
um
[Laughter]
and then uh
somebody said to him like hey you and
neil said he wants to write something
with you and he was like oh really like
it never again literally like a true
romantic comedy yeah he was like what
yeah we could never write anything
and uh and then this was
1997. this is in the 1900s can you
believe how
how i know you know what i mean no i
don't want to i mean you know because
whether they say you know they say life
is short
can i down the nose how do i download it
that's wondering
um and uh 97 so you the first 97 and
then we wrote that movie half fake
together but again like i was writing i
was out here writing for like dating
game shows i wrote for singled out on
mtv and all that on [ __ ]
yeah i wrote for all that on nickelodeon
and uh singled out kevin cal right right
right
right
right
right
right
right right right king kelly yeah i wrote an
episode way to bury the lead i'm sorry
um
so so you're so the half-baked was uh it
was just something you were writing for
fun no no it was no it was it was uh it
was wackier than that
um
chavelle and i had seen i loved it
we had seen trainspotting and uh which
is great yeah and uh and he was like
that you could do like a weed movie like
a weed version of that and i was like
all right and uh
like thought nothing of it like what
more romantic comedy and uh
and then i'd written a script
that was like fine but i had a meeting
with the producer this guy bob simons
and i was just funny in the meeting and
then um
chappelle had a meeting there like two
weeks later and they were like do you
have any ideas and he's like yeah i'm
writing a movie
uh
with a buddy of mine and they're like
who's your buddy it's like don't worry
you never heard of them and they're like
no seriously i swear to god this
happened and he's like they're like no
seriously tell us and he's like neil
brennan and they're like we love neil
[Laughter]
he literally so chappelle calls me and
goes if universal calls tell them we're
writing a weed movie
so
this is and when they called it would be
on a landline there used to be a thing
oh yeah this is a whole other episode so
uh we had a thing called an answering
machine
um if we would put tapes
um it was very stupid uh so then they
called and i was like and so they call
they're like are you and dave right in a
weird movie and i was like hello yeah
yeah exactly
uh yeah
um you thinking about movie and i was
like yeah and they go when can you pitch
it and i was like in 30 days time we'd
never talk to anyone
so
then we like waited till day
29. of course you've been stoned by the
way we're 23. like we're 23. were you
smoking a lot i didn't smoke weed i
don't just don't smoke wow
i don't know that's surprising i know i
know who else does that surprise in here
that's surprising i know i'm just like
this but you must get connected to that
drug a lot people must assume that you
do yeah but you know fine yeah i mean
you have people think you're a coke what
are you gonna do that's true well well
if the shoe fits yeah um um so
we waited next question
sorry day 29 and then uh figured it out
did you have to write it then we
outlined it yeah uh
and like in a day
and it shows um
we outlined it in a day and then we went
in we like just stayed in the mondrian
dave was staying there and like
there's this book uh the writer's
journey by christopher vogler i was like
read that that'll like it's helpful so
we read it he read it and then it was
like we just [ __ ] did it and then we
pitched it the next day and it went well
and it was like and then pitched to the
simons we pitched to bob simon yeah who
who would produce happy girls billy
madison and sure uh of course problem
child yeah and problem shot too and of
course probably um he
did he get it right away was he like oh
this is yeah yeah and then it became
like a montage
like a success montage
that's the the second act of the third
act of the rom-com yeah um yeah
and then he put a pencil behind his ear
and a monster you fall asleep because
you've been telling me yeah like what
and then he'd finish the scene and i'd
wake up it's hilarious
um
so so how that so that was in march of
1997 and we started shooting this is
insane we started shooting in july of
1997. i swear to god
it was so crazy yeah and we're 23. so it
was just like oh and everyone's like by
the way
movies don't get made this quickly i
mean people were like yeah for you
losers they don't
you guys didn't read a certain book yeah
i guess you guys
uh so
and as it's happened today of tons of i
mean i guess not if you're making it
they had a lot of like input but they
didn't have i mean
i don't yeah they it was the the our
version was better than the way the
movie turned out so why i mean why is
that is that the direction it was just
like it wasn't it was they just made it
into like a
goofy ass kaleidoscope but it just it
tanked it [ __ ] yeah but we open
against titanic and uh
really
we are against titanic goldeneye good
will hunting
big lebowski that's correct really who
said who screamed that out oh jeff
bridges is here
uh
we beat you [ __ ] um
who how did you know that somebody
yelled that out
who yelled at anyway okay sorry uh a
knowledgeable heckler
he felt he felt so shamed by it you're
like who oh i was impressed
that was an impressive heckler so we
didn't have a chance what do you do with
hecklers i've always wondered about that
uh do you do do you like engaging with
hecklers uh no i mean sometimes if
they're like sort of if it's if they say
something that makes me say something
funny it's great
[Laughter]
seinfeld has the funniest policy with
hecklers which is he handles them
like a customer service rep
we're like what's your problem sir so
you're unhappy with my comedy yeah and
then they'll be like talk yeah and then
and then it just diffuses yeah
you were on his show you were so good on
the show that is one of my favorite
comedians you gotta see that two
comedians and cars getting caught up
guys you've got a lot of work out for
you yeah a lot of homework there's also
comedians of the world on netflix it's
fun and your podcast uh of course my
podcast i have a podcast called how neil
feel don't worry about it uh it's
episode three that's a goddamn title
short stupid
it's eccentric um uh how good does it
feel to get a laugh from jerry seinfeld
because he was so tickled by you is that
what he said it feels uh tickled he's
moved yeah it's great it's also like
it's
scary to talk to him i bet because he's
like god really funny it's not like he's
smart and all that he jerry's also the
kind of guy that'll be like what
he doesn't he said that you a few times
yeah like what um so yeah you you
mentioned something about uh a
girlfriend you you said oh i bring up
girlfriends that i don't even have yeah
he's like i don't like that yeah i don't
like that oh
yeah uh he's like i don't know you know
what's messed up he had a birth like
we're friends like we've had dinner and
stuff and uh he had a birthday party
a week and a half ago guess who wasn't
invited this guy
and i texted him like hey i bet i was
right on the bubble
for getting invited i must have been
right there and he didn't and he was
like oh hey buddy he didn't read him
like dude he doesn't have to no he
doesn't have to he doesn't have to it's
like yeah it's intimidating for me to be
around people who are that confident who
are handling it pretty well
[Laughter]
but how how
how might
so when you you don't you didn't see him
at all thrown by him you didn't see you
see as i told him like i've been
watching him yeah since i was 10. so
like
i kind of feel like kindred spirits to
begin with and then like i know his act
backward and forward and i know his
friend like i we have a lot of friends
in common like and you did a really
ballsy thing where you admitted that you
didn't watch history i've watched about
five seinfeld my entire life and he says
and neil says well of anybody who would
understand it would be you the most
seinfeld thing you can do is not watch
sci-fi
like if you think anyone on seinfeld
would have watched seinfeld you're out
of your mind and he was like i don't
watch chappelle's show yeah i was like i
don't yeah of course you didn't and
there was no it was just too funny
just fine like he'd i said i don't like
to come he goes yeah i don't like him
either yeah
the one insult i did
levy at him i said every time i watched
seinfeld you guys were worried about a
jacket
and he was like and it he stuck with him
because it's true he's like yeah the
jacket where's the code where's the
jacket yeah um you can't wear that
jacket it was dude there's a puppy code
there's the last thing i'll say about
jerry you had asked him something you
said what is your
what do you say what what are your
mistakes oh yeah when was that he didn't
answer in the he may have answered you
yeah disappointments disappointments
yeah oh he's or i think i said
he said doing stuff for money
ah
which uh like the sitcom he said i'm
kidding um
uh no he said doing stuff for money that
was just doing anything for money other
if you don't have the right
kind of motivation
money cannot be like even like yeah
it'll be easy it's never easy it's just
like it just ends up being bad and like
you have to even his show comedians and
cars he sits in the edit for eight hours
oh no every episode of like use that use
that use that use that because it's so
tight it's 15 yeah and that's his thing
it's like he can take and but it's also
doing a job that you're happy to like do
like i don't yeah i like i like watching
chapel show footage like jerry likes
watching
footage of himself is it the whole day
that you're shooting that show yeah how
much time do you spend with them seven
hours or something wow yeah good god are
there things in your life that you that
you can that relate to that i mean in
terms of doing things for money i mean
you well yeah
anything i've done the trajectory of my
career is i'll do something for like the
love of the thing
i'll get quote unquote hot from it and
then i will squander the hotness
uh what i'm doing like i like after
spell show i directed a movie called the
goods because i wanted to work with uh
jeremy jeremy now i wanted to work with
will ferrell and adam mckay
and the movie was starring jeremy pippen
who and i going into it i was like he's
either can open a movie or he can't i
never really watched enter it was like i
wanted to work with well now i'm right
producing i didn't write it okay so
didn't work like i it wasn't like a
thing i had an idea that was burning a
hole in my pocket that i was like i
don't it's worth waiting
um
five years or whatever like as long as
it takes that's the lesson you learned
just do a thing that you really that you
mean yeah and that's what it is
like then then and then like i was like
i really like doing stand-up so i'll
just do stand-up for
however long i've been doing it and
that's where is it it's 1995. um no i've
been doing it and like so the last 12
years i've been doing stand-up like
every night and the culmination of that
mindset was was is that safe to say it
was three months yeah i did an hour and
a half on comedy central and then i did
three mics on netflix and the
communities of the world thing that came
out at the beginning of the year are you
afraid of saying the wrong thing you
talk uh
not i mean
i kind of feel like
if you grandfather yourself in yeah yeah
like howard stern yes
yeah they just go oh no we don't no but
like my brother doesn't just
he says something
and someone says sir you can't say that
that's racist and he goes no it's okay
i'm racist
oh just lean into it yeah
just go like oh no yeah no it's fine i'm
i'm yeah
how does your brother feel about your
success not good
uh but that you can great you can just
grandfather you just go yeah i don't
what do you what also it's like bill
burrow's joke like what are you gonna do
take his podcast away like
if you don't have any
any like
corporate overlords yeah what are they
gonna
they you know also as comedians like
comedy's never been more popular so the
idea of like comedians are under fire at
arenas like
yeah but like
but does it make you
at all reluctant to do college shows or
to i don't like doing college shows just
because i don't because i do talk about
race in my act and they kids that age
can't discern
between racial and racist
and kids my age can't either i'm kidding
um like they can't discern so it's just
not that much fun like they don't have
any life experience so it's just like
all theoretical and i don't know it's
just not that it's kind of not that's
fun
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and would
shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wonder plus in apple
podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello
i saw louis c.k paula poundstone
um dude trigger warning yeah
do a um this a couple years ago before
the dark times i saw him do um
uh i saw him do
a zog show in new york south korea and
uh he asked he came out people were like
so this is a small little venue and some
people were so
uh excited to see him and everyone had
their phone up you know it's like when
you see concerts now you just see a sea
of
phones and um he very politely uh
asked people to put the phones down and
most of them did i would say like nine
eighty ninety percent did and then he
asked again he's like no seriously um
and then the rest for the most part went
down but there was still
a couple people who put the and i i then
had to say because i had a mic on the
side i said you know really i had to be
like school mom about it yeah put those
phones down you know yeah it was amazing
to me that they were so desperate to
capture this also what the funny thing
about get who
the [ __ ] wants to watch
footage from your iphone don't of
anything like at concerts especially
like
yeah let me see i'd watch 10 minutes of
radiohead at this restaurant right now
i thought you'd never ask does anyone
have radiohead on a tiny screen i know
titan screen yeah i've send it my way uh
a buddy of mine is a uh who's uh the
singer john mayer said that people now
people will like
go to the front of the stage they'll
walk toward him the front of the stage
turn around to their backus to him and
then take a picture
that he's in the background because they
have to tie themselves into it they do
yeah it's just about it's not about him
yeah i went to school with john mayer
and i remember i did i did
i went to high school yeah yeah and he
loves is that how you know him he just
loves yeah he did a sketch
in 2004 so or three or four so i've
known him since then he he um and he was
kind of a shy guy he wasn't at all what
you know the way people think of him now
and he um as far as i knew i barely knew
him but i saw him
well you were a [ __ ] captain of the
football oh yeah i was a big yeah most
likely to succeed to beat the [ __ ] out
of him yeah pretty regularly right i
have a lot of regrets about that i was
um
i made amends to him uh he but yeah but
you did it on twitter so yeah it doesn't
really count um but a lot of people
retweeted it um
so it's valid uh but i remember seeing
him i just done uh galaxy quest hold for
applause yeah
and um i dropped out of school to do it
and um this is like 99 and john i ran
into so i just shot it ahead and come
out yet and i
i went a friend of mine at a party and
he lived across the street from a gas
station i went to the gas station and uh
and john was working behind the counter
and i said he goes hey man i heard about
you shot a movie that's crazy and i was
like i know and i i said how's the music
going i felt kind of you know
he gave you extra gas right again yeah
yeah uh premium yeah unleaded prices um
and and uh and we used to run through
the halls of our high school together
sorry i'm sorry
and i said um i but i was like how's it
going with you you know and i uh trying
to keep be brilliant you know and
positive like and he goes well you know
uh i just recorded a demo in atlanta and
i think things are
you know i'm hoping some and i remember
thinking this is so i can't believe i'm
admitting this but i remember thinking
at the time like you poor bastard oh
yeah you know
everyone's got a demo and
like six months later that song
you know jerry o'connell
so jerry o'connell yeah i know i went to
yeah
jerry said the funniest thing wait i
want you to tell us he said to me once
he goes you know i actually um
used to have a little bit of a stutter
not kidding
yeah he went to nyu when i was there and
when i dropped out to hand out flyers
he walked past me with a bunch of
friends and was like this is neil he
used to go to school with me he'll be
back real soon
but it was like 28 years ago who
remembers stuff like that
do you do your funny stutter impressions
again
i don't remember that
um
uh
how were you at all reluctant to do
three because it's so personal reluctant
uh like it's it's personal slash private
yeah i wasn't real i mean no because i
once i i did it like a short version of
it uh at
the the meltdown like they the on sunset
they had a tv show
and um and so i did like a six-minute
version of it like just and would do
like what three mics is basically one
mics for one-liners one is for like
stand-up and one is for like
hardcore emotional [ __ ]
and like which is depression
alcoholism uh but the stuff with your
father and potentially yeah like my dad
dying and just like like pretty not
graphic but like you know like very
revealing wrenching or whatever yeah um
[ __ ] whatever and uh
and so i wasn't i don't i just kind of
felt like ah this will work i just
thought it would work enough of it i
didn't i just was like i am going to do
this i just was like i had done a comedy
central hour and a half and no one
seemed to care so i was like all right
well i'm not just going to keep doing
this
for no
for nothing yeah like i i it's like
thinking out of it is like well this
will be the last thing and then if they
don't like this then i'll just leave
them alone because you were doing small
to workshop but you do smaller yeah
yeah like i mean not that's i mean not
that small yeah but yeah i would do like
penthouses like this
[Laughter]
uninvited uh yeah
honey there's a comedian at the door uh
you uh you talk in that in that special
in such an honest well i mean one of the
reasons i love your comedy is it's it's
honest it's so honest based on
logic you have such a um
such an interesting point of view but
such an honest point of view and
one of the things you talk about is
being a star [ __ ] and the
the idea that everyone kind of is in in
their own way there is no one and you
liken it to drive the best one it's not
even starbucks but yeah the the analogy
i make is like being
no one acts normal around celebrities
like being relaxed
being with a celebrity is like driving
next to a cop
like you can perform normalcy but you're
not all you're doing is thinking about
the best one will smith who's a friend
um
william smith will smith on his
instagram posted a thing of neymar
who's the like
arguably the most famous athlete in the
world a huge soccer player and neymar
uh scheduled like a meet with a meet and
greet with will yesterday and will and
neymar is like hyperventilating
and can't look at him and it cries a
little bit
but that's endearing that's it's so
endearing yeah i go the other yeah yeah
um
i don't know what that means but uh well
i go the other way with stuff like that
when i'm the few times like we were
talking about who would you be
really intimidated by i mean i think
i've it's been 20 years i've been
working with people who but i you're in
[ __ ] galaxy questions come on but i
remember like meeting philip seymour
hoffman at that time yeah to me was like
name our level you know i if i if i were
to be myself i probably would have cried
a little bit i looked up to him so much
and
and i was introduced to him and he i
instead i try to overcome that by
playing it really cool which i think
probably has the effect of being
like standoffish or aloof yeah you know
uh and you talk about that too you talk
about the that a lot of people think you
are oh yeah that i think they think i'm
cold or bored or superior and it's like
it's that's just clinical depression
oh yeah yeah but
but how bad that baby girl is just
clinical depression
and which of course you can't say to
people when you're meeting
them hate it they don't know much about
socializing they don't like it at all
but i take it the other way i take it
very personally because i'm insecure i i
thought you didn't like me no i really
like i know that now i don't know if you
really like me
are there any things that you feel are
off in your life and your personal life
are off limits to talking about i mean
then for the next three months is there
anything that you no i don't mean i
don't know what not really i mean
there's nothing that i'm like
part of three mikes was like let me just
say like the star [ __ ] thing was like
what's the meanest thing someone could
say about me yeah all right yeah yeah
let me talk about that yeah and kind of
explain it and in which you do yeah and
when you do and that is such an ugly
uh i've been accused of that the only
thing that i'm like
truly
it's ugly i care it's a character yeah
yeah like alcoholism or depression i'm
like that just happened to me but like
no no no welcome that i can't
be normal around celebrities like i
literally go into an i mean it's i it's
kind of i think i'm past it but like
it was a thing to the point where it's
like all right i have to talk about that
but what was it like when you met obama
i mean how bad was it how powerful how
weird were you no with obama it was i
met him with the correspondence center
i wrote for when seth meyers was the uh
hosted like me
me melanie alex bayes
uh like it was we were and then we at
at the correspondents are by the way the
correspondent center is like the most
corrupt thing in the world like how so
because it's like they're all in cahoots
it just feels like
that literally i'm in line to get a
picture with obama yeah and it's like me
and melanie a bunch of people and rupert
murdoch and you're like uh yeah like in
a reception you're like wait i thought
yeah you
it's they're all
sort of in yeah
it's like the business of it it was
creepy that they're all like hey buddy
yeah they're all friends with each other
it's kind of creepy but uh yeah yeah i
just met him at the corresponding center
but that happens sometimes in those um
you know like the senate hearings like
these two like some like kind of racist
like yeah i would be like well i'm
actually good friends yeah jeff sessions
you know and frankenstein
yes i mean it happens all the time uh so
you just think oh you're you're right
it's like this is like wrestling a
little bit yes
um you talk also about your your
breakups you talk very openly about it
has that um and something we've talked
about uh has that made you more
protective uh when it comes to getting
into a relationship you went through two
very difficult ones i'm just not uh
i think i'm accepting
i i went i go to therapy
a couple different ones actually and um
no i was going to therapist and um we're
also sponsored by therapy
um
uh that that ottoman from therapy the
one that matches the chair
the ottoman
um
uh
i no i finally in therapy was like hey
what if my mission in life is not to be
a husband or boyfriend huh what and it
was like she was like yeah and i was and
since i've had that thought i've my
life's gotten better
and i still date and i would and i had a
girlfriend but like the idea of the
pressure i spent so much time feeling
like i was wrong yeah for not uh if i
was in a relationship that i didn't like
i would try to figure out like what
could i do differently or what i need to
force myself to love the innocence like
it's sometimes you're just
not right well we talk about that a lot
because our parents are still together
and we were raised in a very like this
is why this is what you do you meet
somebody
you fall in love you have sex as many
times as it takes
to have kids and they have kids
go ahead three times three times yeah uh
and that's it
um but but that was the conception that
i always had that yeah and so i that
makes sense well it's also but it's also
the thing of like the even the new agey
bad advice is like
relationships are hard work it's like
they not really like they don't have to
be hardcore i understand that they're
like maintenance it's like it's like
you know sleeping in a bed is hard work
it's like no you just got to make the
bed it's not
like having a lawn is the hardest thing
you'll ever no you just mow it
like it doesn't have to be hard work it
can just be like if you really like the
person
uh it shouldn't be that difficult i
agree yeah and uh and i am also a fan of
uh no notes i don't take them and i
don't give them notes don't i don't need
notes you mean like love notes little
like no no no not leaving written
meaning like maybe you need to change
your behavior you want to be fixed i
don't yeah like i'm not looking for a
coach
[Laughter]
and i'm also and i'm not looking to
coach like i don't get like i broke up
with a woman and people were like why'd
you break up with her and i would say
why i don't want to say why but and they
were like well why don't you say
something i was like because you can't
give an adult
corrections yeah
yeah but i think again that's another
misconception that people have about you
should change together you change and
they yeah okay all right well and again
most relationships don't work so most
people are talking out of their ass see
it's i know yeah i know
you're right i can i hear you but then i
it was but you also feel like us i feel
uh a bit of uh i feel like a pariah yep
yeah you go to these parties and you
know and i'm like we're getting to the
age now where it's like it's a little
like it's embarrassing we might as well
have like a giant cold sore on our
mouths
where people are like what's uh what's
going on yeah yeah i'd rather have the
cold sore and be like oh this is my hair
exactly um i got it from
yeah i i but also i'm i'm so susceptible
to
the illusion of social media i think i
mean i see
you know i see people and of course you
only post the good things uh but i think
i think sweeter than a couple who really
peacocks about the relationship and then
they break up it's like oh but what
happened so funny yeah
but i thought
that everything was great and you like
that long post about everything she
taught you life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
hello hello again
uh
uh
i don't i don't know yeah like i i try
to not say anything because i don't get
it uh you know come back and do the work
yeah it's like it's the pink elephant
where they're like so what are you yeah
why are you still dating yeah like what
happened yeah
basically um uh we're basically like
burn victims we're like and we were like
what happened to that guy i'm glad
you're out and man
yeah good for you
for
being in a space with normal people yeah
um
do you think growing up the way you did
i mean do you think yeah i don't think i
don't again and
this is another thing that makes me feel
like a pariah yeah i didn't i've never
there are very few relationships i'm
genuinely jealous of i think a lot of
successful relationships
are you could i could they're like
predetermined like are you
do you have a easygoing disposition
are you like a generally upbeat loving
person then you'll probably have a good
marriage yeah uh i'm a [ __ ] pain in
the ass
how how
yeah yeah
just i'm just like a bit of a crank i'm
quiet i'm like you know i like like
it's so funny you're saying that and i
know and you talk about that i know
you're on it i but you don't strike me
like you're missing through yeah when i
i am
i'm not there
no i know no i'm not like i don't know i
like uh i like this kind of conversation
but i don't i don't like uh
like time wasters
i i dreading dating because of that i'm
dreading sitting down with somebody that
i am
attracted in some ways to but i know
that there's a good read in some ways
thank you um
in terms of an entire meal
um you know just because i and i think
it's one of the reasons we call the show
life is short i i'm that much more aware
of time and i dude i don't know like i
don't know how old everyone listened to
this is i literally feel like
pond casting as a young person's medium
yeah um
instagram for the ears that's why this
is such a lit show
this is pretty this is pretty crunk
today is crunch still a hot word
i don't know i don't know is it crunk
no no no it is it's literally up is this
too sharp
flames flame flame flying flap um you
just say emojis literally feel prayer
hands uh prayer hands prayer hands
flameth influence um
uh i
in life i feel like i'm have one foot
out the door yeah in terms of like oh
i'm almost dead so what do you what were
you gonna say oh yeah i'll come back
what
but for the most part i'm like no i i
like i'm this is pretty much yeah so how
do you so since you're aware of it that
much how
do you ever kick yourself for uh and if
so why for like time that you've spent
no no but here's why did i do that uh
yeah that's like that's like the cost of
doing business like
uh
i i don't get too hung up on time wasted
because that's just like
risk i mean that's just like time you
just go ah this i think this will be fun
and if it's not you're like oh yeah i
did that i judged that wrong yeah um i
like not doing [ __ ] like i don't mean to
i'm way less like
uh
cravingly ambitious than i used to be
now i'm truly more focused on having fun
yeah a buddy of mine died
and um his name was jesus christ
oh here we go here we go
and he died a couple weekends ago and
press stop sound
sound it was two thousand years ago
three weeks ago and you didn't see that
coming did you guys and uh
no well one of my died i was at his
funeral
and uh it was charlie murphy eddie's
brother was entrepreneur great yeah and
at a funeral and i
was just thinking like
i hope he had fun like yeah the idea of
like legacy and all that i just don't
believe in
like i didn't know you're in galaxy
quest what do you know what i mean like
i don't what
like i didn't know like i don't know
like yeah no one talked when was the
last time someone brought up george
carlin in conversation like it doesn't
make a [ __ ] difference like it just
just enjoy yourself
because uh
it all the things that you think are
important are
again this is like the mamas device no
no
i'm just trying to like make my body
secrete serotonin yeah
we we were watching a documentary about
reconstruction don't worry about it guys
and um and and and we were masturbating
furiously yeah um
and we were hearing about booker t walsh
these men who had done in incredible
frederick douglass and
who
who had changed the course of human
history you know and um and and people i
i was like i w e b dubois yeah an easy
name to say and i was like i didn't know
that i didn't know much about them other
than really their names and maybe one
superficial thing about that wildly
important i mean or wildly significant
people yes and and and
with certain people like that it's like
i'm glad frederick douglass did what he
did yeah but certain people it's like ah
you know okay yeah i know
like miranda lloyd or like she has a
screen siren or like yeah it's like okay
our grandmother's 102 and she loved she
grew up during the depression and as an
escape would go to go to movies and so
she started fetishizing
these like little actresses and yeah
i don't think that got passed down
genetically but um i i i so she she has
this obsession with and she i said well
like who you know what and she started
naming people like and i'm sure they've
never heard of any of them never heard
of them and they you know how worried
these women were oh you know how you
know how much of these women's lives
were spent worrying about like yeah i
got to get an audition
by the way
um that joke maybe my favorite joke of
the whole podcast got nothing um
uh but no but like really really should
have laughed at that scene hey
uh really
like consumed by a bunch of [ __ ] and
they might as well have
just tried to focus on something that
made them feel good was was there a path
that your life could have taken where
you would have ended up kind of consumed
by that
what do you think
had it not been for black well i don't
know not really like
like an old man appeared to me bag or
vance yeah um
uh no there was never like uh
i've been pretty like lucky in terms of
just like i like this and it's the other
thing i would tell like my i don't know
if you relate to this just like it's all
gonna be fine
like
it's all gonna be fine like
our imaginations are far worse than
reality in terms of like if i don't do
this then this is going to happen
and then it's fine this is going to be
really quick i know you have to go uh
what's your favorite emoji
what's the most what's your go-to i
literally was thinking about it today
you know you'll like this
you know the uh
the emoji where the guy has just the
flat mouth
and then he has the flat asian eyes
that's why you like it um
because it's racist so you'll enjoy it
i'm sure um i just like it because it is
like
i just it's like i feel that it could be
and it's multifunctional probably i like
the white guy doing the wakanda symbol
that's a big one when you do when you
that's good
when you do those guys do you
consciously do white you make them white
yeah because you know i don't know i
told a bunch of black friends of mine uh
and they were outraged that white
women will sometimes send black fist
emojis and they're like don't you dare
don't you [ __ ] dare but is there
occasion to send a white fist
i mean
maybe northern ireland yeah when you win
another election hello
um mega guys
um if you could be a professional
athlete uh what what sport would you
play do you
love it i'm not i just like watching it
i enjoy it if you could have one snack
food for the rest of your life what
would what would it be um
smokehouse almonds from uh blue diamond
almonds oh yeah yeah big that got a big
response bigger were you clapping bigger
response than galaxy quest or
frederick douglass
or frederick douglass or working in
or working in jonestown yeah um
what is our sponsor as well um
what's your favorite movie of all time
um
city of god maybe yeah city of god or
like the apartment or you know what
movie i like
wall street oh yeah like i used to watch
wall street ad nauseum and i like it's
the right it's campy and [ __ ] it's just
i like it yeah did you like the shia
labeouf no no
the beef um
other than la or new york where would
you want to live
um
in your eyes okay um
i would say let's see
let's go with uh
tokyo oh yeah or really
hong kong because hong kong's near the
near the equator although i like tokyo
better as a city i do a great impression
of a guy from i can only imagine um
if
off the air off the air if you could
have dinner is it justin off the air
please
uh favorite muppet
never really watched them up really yeah
um gasp i gasped from them from the
crowd i hope this is the youngest of ten
so that's the thing is you don't get to
pick oh when you watch so like i just
heard about mr rogers
what would they watch
they'd watch like happy days and welcome
back hotter and like you know
yeah laverne and shirley
so there's no uh there was much not much
of a democracy with with ten kids
um
we our older brother used to line up our
cups and he would pour because we got to
have one helping of soda a night and he
would line up the cups we got no we
weren't allowed to drink so we could
watch an hour of tv a week a week uh
yeah
jesus could you space it out throughout
the week
yeah i guess you could but like i don't
know if you know how tv works but they
generally
do it in a half hour an hour a second so
i'd watch an act of happy days so you'd
blow it all on wall street yeah exactly
with louis rookies um if you could
either have a super x-ray vision or
super hearing which would you choose
uh i guess vision um one age for the
restaurant i wish i could hear
who wants to hear well
well if i can only imagine what they're
saying right now i just raised
his hand ah yeah but then you could hear
you know you could know what's going but
i don't want to right i'm also
if you've learned nothing we need to get
beyond what people are saying but just
like i don't care
enjoy yourself yeah it never do you
remember the last time something like
that really affected you oh i mean i'm
not saying
over here
you know you know the instagram thing i
mean we don't have time to talk about it
but i thought this was so interesting
you post you reposted something that
somebody sent to you oh yeah woman
dm going like if you weren't a b or c
question mark parentheses list celebrity
we could maybe get along also can you
get me tickets to chappelle and aziz in
uh not kidding
yeah yeah uh i really think you were
just a i really think you if you were
just a normal ass i love that normal ass
yes normal ass dude and not a bc list
celebrity we would and so you posted
this and said you said how not to dm
somebody each sentence is worse than the
previous and people kind of got pissed
about me people got mad at p i lost
followers somebody said somebody and you
reposted this too they said uh ugh
seriously you're calling someone a
narcissist while being offended that
they had the audacity to call you a
bella celeb get over yourself i read her
message and then went on to say how much
they liked you
uh i'm not kidding you're not kidding me
no i know and they said lighten the [ __ ]
up i'm really angry on and on to the
longest i can't read it because i do
think you're hell because i do think
you're hilarious i love your work i bet
she does too support your this is crazy
support your fans in whatever [ __ ] up
love they give you
that's a quote quote and to which you
responded please shut the [ __ ] up
yeah
um
so
i loved that i i love that you called
them out and and but it created this
whole back and forth again follow neil
on instagram um yeah so i think we have
to now shut the [ __ ] up uh i wish we
didn't because this has been so you know
in the future when you get a big
applause like that yeah you're going to
want to just start the outro then i see
it
and then you go like all right well this
is all the time again you do like you
and then they keep applauding well this
is all the time we have oh [ __ ] they're
not applauding let's see i see um well
thank you thank you
thanks for having me buddy it was fun
thanks um and thank you guys for for
being here thanks for coming to the
penthouse yes
[Music]
[Applause]
well now it's weird not to have an
audience for so
that happened it's weird for
you just to be talking to me yeah i
think you're going to be performing to
me now i don't know what you're talking
about
did you feel a real difference in terms
of
your uh performance in the conversation
did you did you find yourself performing
more than you would if you were
absolutely interested absolutely i i
hadn't thought about it until you just
said that but yeah
i did because i'm sorry to make you
self-conscious well no it's interesting
uh yeah there was how many people were
there i would say
yeah well you know both everything
um 60 maybe 61.
um
yeah there were it was a healthy crowd
in a penthouse and it's really cool at
the sonos building um
and i did and some of whom i knew i we
had invited friends
uh
which accounts for some of the laughs i
suppose i noticed you were a little
extra extra you were a little extra yeah
you were like our friend jerry o'connell
hosted the wendy williams show um guest
hosted a few times and he he told us
that that was a criticism of his that he
read on instagram that people said he
was extra
he was a little too much is that what
you're saying thing uh you you laughed a
little harder oh a little bigger you um
like that a little bigger than god but
not
things that i would notice because i
know you so well but i don't i don't
think it was in any way obvious but now
that i'm no i'm making it obvious well i
also want me you know maybe it's it's
also this maybe it's just not any much
better for for my phoniness but but
maybe
i i find neil so funny
and i he's somebody that and i value
humor so much
i really admire him and i want him to
like
so maybe i kind of pushed it a little
bit because of that maybe i mean i don't
mean to [ __ ] on the on the performance i
thought you did a really really good job
that's interesting i noticed a slight
difference in totally normally
because you're aware of the fact that
people are responding to something yeah
so that's why i don't think i could ever
be a stand-up comedian because i'm too
aware to the point where when i do a
play i take my i wear contact lenses i
have like pretty bad vision and uh
it helps me to to not wear my contacts
on on stage or or if i'm shooting
something uh shooting a movie
bit it because it makes everybody else
blurry i mean it kind of helps with the
illusion that they're not there that
it's certainly not that they're not like
you know whole people
living breathing people who who might
judge me which is why this is so nice
and comfortable because like you said oh
no i'm judging you well well you are but
nobody else is
uh
so i i but that i didn't have that you
eased into it uh really nicely i thought
you got much more comfortable after the
first couple minutes like you said that
was that was noticeable to me you know
what helps is getting and whereas i
stayed uncomfortable throughout
because i was awkwardly well yeah that
seating arrangement was awkward but also
what helps was is embarrassing to admit
but getting a laugh you know of course
and you get a laugh it's like oh no okay
now i met some of the confidence back no
but also i think it it really helped to
have neil as
the the first guest of one of these live
shows neil
uh because he is so comfortable in front
of a live audience you know he's yeah
he's not only a comfortable
person he really is but just what he
does for a living you know he's so used
to
doing stand-up comedy but the
interesting thing about him is that the
most interesting thing to me is that
he comes across as and he talks about
this
in his special but
he comes across as such
a confident
sure of himself person and he's done so
many things throughout his career that
would indicate that he's a very
confident person but yet
he also talks about being
depressed and sad and and he just
someone who's depressed and sad
i never imagined that they had they
would have this kind of cool ease about
them like neil does i know but that's
just it's it's a good lesson to learn i
think because yeah but nor do i i mean i
can i think of depressed people as
morose as being morose like eeyore you
know like oh things aren't good yeah and
there's something awkward about sad
people because because they don't feel
comfortable in their surroundings they
don't know how to express themselves but
he's so good at expressing i know well
he's an example of somebody and i really
admire this type of person who has done
so much see seems to have done so much
work on himself to the point where he's
able to speak openly and honestly
publicly and without any reservations
well he he did say he he has he's been
in therapy for a long time and he has
these codependency issues and he talks
about you know relationships he's been
in where he he kind of loses himself and
and i guess it makes sense that he's
worked on himself because now uh hearing
him talk it it it really surprises me
that he would ever have co-dependency
issues because he seems so independent
and he talks about in that interview
uh he talks about
liking
kind of to be alone and and he likes
doing nothing sometimes and he doesn't
seem like someone who needs to have
you know to be in a relationship in fact
the opposite it seems the opposite it's
very rare to meet somebody like that who
is so kind of just comfortable in in
their in their own shoes and where they
are in life but maybe that's after a lot
of work oh maybe sure maybe
i'm sure it is 12 years ago he would
have come across very differently the
fact that he was this film school
dropout
and
didn't really have any money or
connections and his dad never encouraged
me no no no
certainly
but but here's the guy who has the balls
to
you know give these established
comedians advice and
how does that guy how does that guy
who's capable of doing such a confident
act how is he a depressed person i know
but but i know but maybe they're not
maybe that's what i'm saying
i don't think they are and we we
consider that's part of the
that's something that probably should be
demystified about
depression you know is that it can it
happens to
everyone it can happen to anybody
somebody who there's no
there there's no type that it afflicts i
think there's no it manifests itself i
think in in in many different ways and
and so
it's you know they can they walk among
us and and that's why it really helps to
god i mean this theme keeps coming up
but like i love getting to know people
better and and it immediately helps have
empathy for where for who they are and
where they're coming from and yeah i do
remember meeting neil years ago and
thinking and we talked about this in the
interview thinking he didn't really like
me you know that thinking he was uh
and and and he mentioned he says that
well it was just because i was like uh i
wasn't that sad and and had i known that
then had i known what i know about him
now i wish i had because i would have
like really wanted to cultivate a fan
again and not to labor it but
he just never seems sad it doesn't seem
that's not sad looks like to me but i
think you're right that
uh sadness and depression and that can
take all sorts of different forms
you guys talk a lot about seinfeld and i
thought it was so funny that he's never
really seen the show but yet he comes
off he comes across as
someone who's watched a lot of seinfeld
yes you know he kind of sounds a little
bit like
jerry he does he has kind of cool i mean
there's a little bit of a breezy yeah
it's quality throwaway quality he has
that's how he's avoided seinfeld
and i want to say as i do other people i
admire and whose sense of humor i i
admire i want to like encourage him to
watch it it's such actually the first
few years ugh it's just he i was missing
out on so much i know he reduced it too
every time he watches it his joke is
that they're always talking about a
jacket and and it's that's funny but
it's um it's totally untrue i think like
jerry he has they both have this sort of
devil may care at it
um that's an old i haven't heard that in
a while and i think it applies i've
never heard it on a podcast
[Laughter]
from like a 30 year old yes
he had a real devil may care attitude
but doesn't that apply to him it's like
you're talking about errol flynn yeah he
has a real devil may character like i
don't i don't care what people also
think they're dashing anymore
no they say like hunk hunky
hot when you think dashing who's the
first person that comes to your mind
arrow flynn that's why i oh really
or clark gable i would say tom brady oh
well i think of old-timey handsome men
like clark gable or
maybe i
dashing maybe like rudolph valentino or
something
that's really that's way too old no but
i think like how he's a swashbuckler
okay you think of tom brady huh i do i
mean i wonder if he like just stares in
himself i wonder if he admires himself
more than other people do he takes a lot
of stuff being good looking necessarily
makes no i know well it's just like you
know being a depressed person doesn't
necessarily make you moroes that's true
tom brady might think he's hideous
that's true he might have a problem with
his
perfect contoured like his cheekbones
are too chiseled the lesson here is be
really nice to good-looking people
because you don't know what they're
going to do you don't know if they know
they're good that's true
be extra nice today to a good-looking
person everybody
that john mayer story is so good uh i've
told that story
not as me i i don't lie and say that
this thing happened to me but i i tell
your story of seeing john mayer at that
gas station he's really so often it's so
good but do you remember when when we
ran into him years later at the uh
he's saying the shuttle right now
but it was at the chateau mormont and um
he was very concerned with the
apocalypse i remember and like having a
survival kit ready and i remember
thinking that's a little crazy
but uh the closer we get to a potential
apocalypse the more i think he he was
right he was right about that demo tape
he sure was yeah
oh my god yeah uh i yeah my i remember
just thinking
ah good luck
you know everyone's got a dream
your body's a wonderland yeah
he's never going to buy that he would
say that all the time uh i hope jerry
o'connell wasn't offended by yeah jerry
we love jerry and we don't think he has
a stutter sometimes he just gets caught
on words he it's like he trips over
as do i i mean for of all people to talk
i i you can hear it i trip all the time
um in terms of the lightning round
questions i the short questions
uh i think it says a lot about him
that he never
tried to think of something like if
something didn't come to him right away
he was honest yeah so if something came
to him his an answer came to him he
would just say it yeah but if nothing
came to him right away
he didn't go searching for things
he was very comfortable saying ah i
don't know who i did i i really admire
that
i think it says a lot about him it
encapsulates who he is
he's cool but i can see why people think
he's cold yeah yeah hopefully you guys
thought neil was cool hopefully you
enjoyed it i can't believe i survived
first just barely barely survived first
live podca i hope we do more of those
that was fun well i hope i'm not up
there now well i hope you are but that
we just uh we clarify what the situation
is well whatever we'll
we'll cross that live bridge when we
come to it life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
thanks for listening to life is short if
you enjoyed the show maybe you want to
give us a five star review that would
help us out a lot and it would ensure
that the show keeps going we're
available on apple podcast spotify
google podcasts and every major
listening app as well as wondering.com
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's produced by christian long and
megan monaco michelle lanz is our senior
producer and it's executive produced by
marshall louis and ernan lopez for
wondering
[Music]
okay
i got a new driver's license
did i tell you about that
no have you seen my old license with my
crossed eyes yeah i fell on you okay
no
stop it
stop
oh my god
i can't believe they let you do that she
was
reluctant but she was like are you sure
this is what you want
you're like a frankenstein
you're like give you photoshops and
bolts into my neck please
they're like well okay
and then at the end she i was like oh
she's being so nice to like let me do
this it's insane it's insane
that's crazier than the texas one i know
i don't know how i'm gonna outdo this
one
let you do that
and then she goes she's like she thought
about it for a little bit she was like
she's like i can't okay i mean if it's
what you want she could she said well
technically
she said we can i guess this the
thing they need is that they can see the
color of your eyes
oh well then that could have changed
then you could have been like
it looks like
and you have to look into the thing you
can't like look away no
that is terrifying
you